Hi I'm Mohamed Chebaro,
I'm the Bureau Chief, MBC-Al Arabiya television
in London.
Will the Obama administration improve the
world in 2009?
I guess the world today is at the junction
that it can-- things can only -- could only
get better.
And that as well the world has deceived us
before and the world did not improve.
Basically the economic crisis, all the troubles
around the world.
It's a lot for and administration, let alone
for a new president like Obama.
But there is only one thing ahead and that
is human hope.
With human hope which is not high today, but,
we can look forward.
Many crisis could be challenging, economics
as one, wars, problems in the middle east.
I guess, more or less, if we can manage these
crisis with the Obama administration, it could
be good and show some slight improvement.
But not to put high hopes because in four
years, it's too short to even start resolving
even the basics of these issues.